[Musica]
stasera abbiamo la fortuna di parlare di
cambiamenti ovviamente cerchiamo di
pagare dei cambiamenti positivi dopo
questo break che tra l'altro ci voleva
diciamolo perché abbiamo parlato di cose
molto serie io vorrei parlarvi del
cambiamento operato da una donna
iraniana e qualche anno fa pochissimo
tempo fa realtà nel mondo della
matematica
poi la parola matematica molti di voi si
riterranno perché non tutti hanno avuto
un'esperienza positiva con la matematica
però la matematica è la regina delle
scienze e bellissima ovviamente io sono
la matematica e penso questo e voi
sapete che le donne sono state ben poche
nel mondo della matematica nei secoli se
ne sono viste 34 a cominciare c'è anche
un'italiana maria gaetana agnesi la
famosa ipazia
germain che ha collaborato dirigere la
tour eiffel ma si contano sulle dita
della mano destra però diciamo
recentemente c'è stato uno sviluppo
enorme infatti
dal 2014
per la prima volta una donna ha vinto la
medaglia fields che l'analogo del nove
per la matematica è stata la prima donna
è finora l'unica donna purtroppo ti anni
dopo è venuto a mancare questo è stato
un lutto tremendo della matematica
io avevo avuto la fortuna di trovarmi lì
quando questo è successo lì intendo a
seoul in corea del sud lì c'è stato il
congresso internazionale dei matematici
che avviene ogni quattro anni e in
quell'occasione vengono assegnate le
fils medal che sono appunto l'analogo
del nove per la matematica
quando è stato fatto il suo nome si
girava un po la voce io ho questo
ricordo fortissimo di questa grandissima
nella sala a seul con 5mila matematici
presenti di cui 3.000 donne perché così
tante donne perché si sentiva girava la
voce con la donna ce l'avrebbe fatta
quando materialmente è stato fatto il
suo nome
io ricordo un urlo poderoso cianciano
tutte in piedi io stessa con le lacrime
agli occhi dalla contentezza finalmente
una donna c'era riuscita ora da quel
giorno la motivazione per la sua
vittoria è stato per il contributo che
lei ha dato allo studio di alcune
superficie che si chiamano superficie di
iban e degli spazi e la tv dei moduli
adesso qui andiamo sul tecnico eviterò
di farlo naturalmente ma mai ammessa
cani ovviamente era stata informata una
delle cose belle della storia e che
viene informata come lei era all'epoca
del fatto professore a stanford negli
stati uniti e gli arriva un messaggio di
posta elettronica dal presidente
dell'unione matematica internazionale
dicendo cara marian hai vinto la fim
nylon e lei ha pensato che fosse uno
scherzo affatto di liz ha cancellato il
messaggio il giorno dopo abbiamo detto
guarda ma la cosa si è riferito la fim
mega alle a quel punto è rimasta molto
stupita assolutamente non se l'aspettava
bene è perché perché lei aveva anche una
personalità particolare ecco io vorrei
raccontarvi brevemente il personaggio
qui vedete dalle foto che ho scelto
della sua figura piccola fragile era
molto fragile infatti era già malata
quanto ha vinto il premio aveva questi
splendidi occhi azzurri lei
diciamo era nata a teheran aveva una
famiglia borghese
iraniana tipica ma molto propensa ad
aiutarla quando si scoprì che aveva un
talento per la matematica scuola come
spesso succede
le spicciola che una scuola speciale per
ragazze particolarmente dotate di la sua
insegnante verificò questo fatto che le
era molto bravo allora il fatto è che a
lei non interessava realtà la matematica
che voleva fare la scrittrice
leggeva tutto quel che poteva
era determinata a fare la scrittrice
seno che partecipò la padrona
partecipare alle olimpiadi della
matematica nel 94 e 1994
195 per la squadra olimpica iraniana
vista la medaglia d'oro la prima volta
che anche la seconda questo la fece
assurgere una popolarità incredibile nel
suo paese ma soprattutto
diciamo la spinse nella direzione di
questa scienza e fece domanda
l'università di harvard dopo
l'università e delle presa ora dobbiamo
immaginarci questa piccola ragazza
iraniana sul timido che va ad arona e le
danno come advisor uno che aveva vinto
sua volta la fis medal e lavorava un
settore estremamente sofisticato
marian che era una persona molto
semplice disse ad un collega non ho
capito assolutamente nulla di quello che
ha detto oggi a lezione questa era la
prima lezione che l'ha seguito come
studente di pc di all'università di
harvard
se non che dopo tre anni tanto ci si
mise di impegno tanto era bravo anche il
suo advisor scrisse una tesi onerosa che
ha cambiato il corso della storia in
quel settore
raccontando ho trovato delle formule su
delle curve speciali che si chiamano
geodetiche che si possono disegnare su
superfici le tipo che il tic e lei
studiava ecco in questa immagine che
vedete questo è il suo modo di lavorare
lei metteva dei grandi fogli di carta
per terra si metteva ginocchio con un
penna bello e calcolava disegnava quando
si sposò ed ebbe una bambina una figlia
la figlia e l'ha impressionata da questo
modo di lavorare dalla mamma e la
guardava c'è una bellissima foto in cui
la figlia guarda ecco qui si vede la
bambina quanto lei questi sono i
vincitori della fish perda nel 2014 a
seul guardava la mamma dice a mamma ma
che cos'è questo che fai un disegno
giochi non stai lavorando chiaramente
però lei stava lavorando e come allora
bisogna pensare che a quel punto lei era
ma oramai già abbastanza nota nel
settore matematica non era celebre come
quando ha vinto la fidal dopo harvard
ebbe una borsa di studio a princeton con
il claim si gioca for diciamo sostiene
le persone molto talent a te in tre anni
scrisse tre articoli poderosi sulle
migliori riviste di matematica ea quel
punto ha meno di 30 anni
le offrirono una cattedra stanford lei
andò a stanford mise su famiglia e
continuava ad avere questo profilo
modesto diciamo non si vantava però ogni
volta che partecipava qualcosa
succedevano a doha sentire un seminario
a
l'università di stanford punto e cerali
un grande matematico territori anche lui
vincitore fish nadal che notava questa
ragazza sul fondo che alzava la mano
faceva delle domande pazzesche cioè lui
stessa vale serie difficoltà a
rispondere però capì che era una persona
straordinaria
ora quando vinse la film è dal sisma
vedete che nel suo paese in cui le donne
vengono trattati insomma non proprio
come dovrebbero deciso addirittura di
toglierle il velo la raffigurano senza
il velo che fu una cosa che fece
leggenda proprio e la foto che vedete
accanto a lei con la sua amica è stata
amica tutta la sua vita all
alla gara molto la partenza per andare a
partecipare alle olimpiadi della
matematica
mariam ha lasciato una traccia enorme è
stata un cambiamento poderoso nella
matematica allora voi dovete pensare
dunque lei è venuta a mancare dopo tre
anni perché ha avuto un cancro che non
l'ha perdonato ha minimamente però ha
scritto lui fatto nell'ultimo periodo
gli ultimi della sua vita un teorema
talmente poderoso che è stato chiamato
il teorema della bacchetta magica perché
perché utilizzandolo si possono
dimostrare numerose altre cose in altri
settori della matematica
non proprio legate tra di loro quindi
lei era veramente una poliglotta nella
matematica sapeva varie teorie
perfettamente dalla in grado di usarle e
questo teorema che gli inglese sono
anche più bello al night magic wand tir
il teorema della bacchetta magica è
quello in cui diciamo ha perso la sua
vitalità perché poi è venuta a mancare
quando morì tutti quanti fu un cordoglio
universale allora al convegno successivo
per la matematica a rio de janeiro la
cappa della donna della società
matematica iraniana disse ok facciamo
qualcosa per lei istituiamo un giorno
per magra mezzacane quale poteva essere
giorno migliore che non il suo giorno di
nascita 12 di maggio come la facciamo
questa cosa prendiamo una donna per ogni
continente le mettiamo insieme e queste
devono studiare degli eventi ogni anno
per ricordare variando i saccani e già
che ci siamo per ricordare tutte le
donne nella matematica celebrating women
and mathematics e questo è avvenuto
quest'anno è stata la quarta edizione di
questa mail to hell maggio 12 la cosa
bella che all'inizio c'è stato appositi
io ho avuto l'onore di rappresentare
l'europa in questo gruppo di donne ed è
stato un esperienza magica ecco qui c'è
il poster che riunisce alcune delle
locandine della degli eventi quanti
tantissimi in tutto il mondo sono stati
organizzati centinaia in un caso
addirittura migliaia di eventi
calcoliamo che poi c'è stata la pandemia
nonostante la pandemia sono stati
egualmente organizzati gli eventi nella
mia università roma tor vergata
ci siamo letteralmente dannati per avere
la speaker in presenza con mascherina
non tutti mascherati nessuno presente
tutti online ma non volevamo mancare a
questo appuntamento
secondo me estremamente importante
perché non solo per ricordare maria
mezzacane ma per ricordare il fatto che
le donne nella matematica esistono e
sono estremamente
brave brave non solo un gran numero
calcolato e che adesso se non ci fosse
stata la guerra il congresso
internazionale dei matematici si sarebbe
tenuto a san pietroburgo
purtroppo 6 al 14 di luglio purtroppo a
causa delle restrizioni
imposte dal fatto nella situazione che
veramente grave è stato trasformato per
la prima volta nella storia di un secolo
di questo congresso in un evento online
l'unico vantaggio è che non si deve
pagare per partecipare che non è poco
perché la quota di partecipazione era
piuttosto alta non andremo a san
pietroburgo in cinquemila come abbiamo
fatto nel passato la cosa che
personalmente mi addolora di più è che
le donne invitate a parlare a questo
congresso calcoliamo che questo è uno
degli onori massimi che può avere un
matematico nella sua vita essere un
invited speaker al congresso
internazionale matematici in percentuale
le donne per l'ultima volta erano
l'undici per cento voi capite che una
percentuale molto bassa
quest'anno erano il 20 per cento
significa che miami usa cani ha dato una
specie di spinta al mondo femminile
tematica tanto coraggio perché le donne
più che altro non hanno la forza interna
la grinta per riuscire come gli uomini
anche perché a volte hanno meno tempo
girano sulle famiglie fanno anche altre
cose è anche non hanno ad una quantità
di stereotipi e norme che le blocca però
è un fatto che un risultato concreto di
questa situazione c'è quest'anno sono il
20 per cento di questo 20 per cento
quattro sono italiane questo è un altro
grandissimo onore perché
le donne italiane
diciamo non appare sui giornali tutti i
giorni ma sono molto bravo in matematica
e una dunque sono michela procesi curino
ciclare gabriella tarantello e barbara
fantetti lavorano in varie università
italiane e io pur essendo
un'osservatrice a questo punto della mia
vita di tutto questo penso che sia
veramente meraviglioso che ci sia una
presenza italiana così importante al
congresso internazionale dei matematici
2022 che avviene online avrete letto
sicuramente la notizia che una giovane
matematica ucraina è stata investita da
un missile a kharkiv all'inizio della
guerra ed uccisa nel mondo della
matematica può essere stato un lutto
enorme perché perché ovviamente era
giovane era brava aveva vinto anche lei
delle olimpiadi come maria mezzacane e
la sua vita è stata stroncata da questo
missile russo ora nel mondo della
matematica questo è stato un fatto
epocale
abbiamo organizzato mille cose io mi
trovo in varie organizzazioni che
aiutano diciamo a ricordare questi
eventi a promuovere le donne matematica
e il fatto di questa iuliano che è
veramente una perla non dà l'anima tica
è una cosa che ci ha colpito a tutti
molto chiuderò facendo un piccolo
appunto la situazione della guerra in
ucraina ha inciso moltissimo in tutto il
mondo della scienza e anche in quello
della matematica come abbiamo detto il
congresso internazionale si doveva
svolgere la san pietroburgo non si
svolgerà lì ma online e bisogna capire
che la lim all international
mathematical union che organizza questo
congresso ha deciso di impedire ai russi
di partecipare all'organizzazione questo
ha lasciato tutti un po scioccati però i
matematici russi che sono stati invitati
come invited speakers perché bravi
potranno ugualmente fare loro conferenze
anche questo all'inizio non era chiaro
ora
certamente e doloroso pensare che il
mondo della scienza possa essere diciamo
frenato da un evento bellico è un fatto
e quello che sta succedendo gli
scienziati hanno reagito c'è stata una
drammatica lettera in febbraio di 80
matematici contro questa situazione che
ovviamente non ha sortito alcun effetto
però è un fatto che tutti noi sentiamo
quante terribile situazione non solo per
la guerra di per sé ma anche per il
mondo della scienza poiché riteniamo che
la scienza sia un santuario un posto in
cui si dovrebbe lavorare in pace e la
parola pace con cui chiudo è quella che
mi auguro che vinca su tutto questo e
spero anche ardentemente che il 5 di
luglio tra pochi giorni quando helsinki
verrà proclamata fran proclamati quattro
nuovi vincitori della fish megan mi
auguro che tra di loro ci sia di nuovo
una donna così potremo ricordarci di
mariani grazie